greetings [__] it's monday i
don't know what the [__] the date is
i know it's spring and i know we're back
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
draftkings listen it's almost april
and the tournament [__] insanity is
heating up
let me tell you something you got to get
into this [__] tournament action
whether you like college basketball you
don't especially what
draftkings are serving up now you ready
for this one better dollar
on any tournament game if your team wins
you win a hundred dollars did i not tell
you draftkings is the number one rated
sports book app or you think i'm just
[__] around with you people here
if your team wins you win a hundred
dollars bet a dollar on any tournament
game
it's that simple pick any college team
that's still in the running for your
shot at winning
a hundred dollars and all it takes is
one
[__] dollar one dollar into a hundred
dollars
is 100 to one odds these kinds of odds
are once in a [__] lifetime
and draftkings is bringing them to you
on a [__] monday
during this madness this [__]
insanity there's no better way to put
your college basketball knowledge
to the test than when you put your money
where your mouth is with draftkings
sportsbook app oh college ball ain't for
you well i'll tell you what's going on
this weekend they're also giving you 100
odds on select fighters at this
weekend's ufc 250.
what'd you forget tyrone wooley's on the
card stephen mayo chick is on the card
um was on the card i mean we got a great
[__] ufc card
so if college ain't for you then
saturday night
ufc 260 is draftkings is safe
secure reliable withdraw your money when
you want it's your money
now what what do you want to do you want
to keep [__] around with these mickey
mouse little [__] bedding services
or go with the top-rated draft king
sportsbook app right now
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app
use promo code joy when you sign up to
turn a dollar
into a hundred if the college basketball
team of your choosing
pulls off the win that's code joey to
turn
one dollar into a hundred dollars for a
limited time only
at draftking sportsbook hold on there's
fine print you got to be 21 older go
back and get the [__] kazoo
come back and see me when you're 21. new
jersey indiana pa
new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem
you got to take care of that this is not
for you
call 1-800 gambler if you're in jersey
or in indiana 1-809 with it
but if you're straight [__] the
party starts today let me tell you what
i got on top of you [__] today
oklahoma versus getting 14 and a half
from gonzaga this afternoon you still
got time
and you got colorado getting two points
from florida [__] state you got
tyrone woodley this weekend you got sean
o'malley you got on gayo versus tp
listen this is the weekend for you
download draftkings right now
press encode joey and let's turn a
dollar into a hundred dollars
the joint is also brought to you by
cbdlion.com
when it comes to cbd the best tried
surgery i just went through surgery with
them i've been off the pain pills why
cbd lion has helped me that much do you
understand me
whether it's the gummies whether it's
the kinesiology tape
chocolate bar tincture the long style
kinesiology tape bath balls
i mean listen let's do this just go to
cbdlion.com right now
and see what they got read read about
cbn cbd
cby see the advantages how it can help
you this
company is no joke this is real cbd
and i'm telling you they took care of me
over this surgery i'm walking i'm
jumping i'm doing whatever i need and
thanks to cbd line so do me a favor go
to cbdlion.com right now
press and co joey church you're gonna
get 20
off delivered right to your [__]
house do you understand me
cbd line right now co joey church
delivered right to your house the joint
is also brought to you by
spring is in beer you're ready for love
when it comes your way
make sure you have all the confidence
where it counts if you know what i'm
talking about
that's why i'm showing up here with blue
chew you combat
all forms of vd erectile dysfunction
blue chew brings you the first chewable
dick pill
it don't taste that bad either same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
and a fraction of the course this isn't
no [__] snakes
[__] skin that your friend brought
you back from
this is science blue chew is an online
prescription service no visits to the
[__] doctor
no awkward conversations some [__]
pharmacist giving you a [__] the
malukai
no waiting online the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com
talk to one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you receive the prescription within days
it ships right to your door in a
discrete package
even the [__] nosy mailman won't know
what's in there bluetooth tablets are
made
right here in the usa they're prepared
and shipped directly
and they're way cheaper than what you'd
getting at a pharmacy
listen even if your dick hurts i know a
lot of you guys are young
and you got good dick as it is but hey
listen
you want to show up with the best dick
in town you know what i'm saying you
want her to call you back and go what
the [__] was that the other night so do
me a favor
go to blue chew i got a special deal for
you try blue chew for free
joy what are you talking about free it's
free use promo code joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluechew.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
free as always and i want to thank
fluchu
for sponsoring the joint listen this is
the way to go
i'm telling you right now you want to
give her a stabbing
that she'll remember for the rest of her
[__] life
go right now to bluechute.com and press
and call joey at checkout
i want to thank buchu i want to thank
cbd lion and draftkings
let's get this [__] party
started it's monday [__]
i'm gonna burn my [__] fingers here
there you go
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Applause]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 22nd i don't know what the [__] it
is the 21st all i know is spring is
finally [__] here
i got over my first winter in new jersey
i'm not going [__] anyway it was one
of the mildest winters i have ever
experienced
i mean knock on wood it ain't over yet
but it was supposed to snow friday
and it didn't and uh i'm [__] happy
about it we had a great weekend
friday night i mean listen man it's it's
been a whole different life like i told
you guys
i've been to jersey i got a social life
again
i'm doing [__] i haven't done in [__]
30 [__] goddamn years
and it feels great man uh what did i do
this weekend let me see friday night i
went to uh
my friend's i mean i know her since i
was
do you guys remember when i told you i
hit on a milf when i was 14.
like 15 i [__] hid in the bushes and
i was going to tackle her in the park
and all this
it was her birthday like she's like 70
now
and she's tight with my daughter out of
all people
my daughter loves this woman because
remember she was my
friend's mother-in-law so now i hang out
with my friend you know he's 60 now i'm
and he has his mother-in-law living with
him the hot one and i told him that i
hit on her and i was gonna tackle her
and [__]
suck her titties and [__] and now she's
like 78 and hey
how [__] crazy is that that my
daughter
and her get along great her name is faye
and my daughter is eight and my daughter
goes down there she plays with the dogs
and then she disappears and her and faye
go in the living room and they watch the
disney channel
and my daughter explains everything to
faye like hey this is this this is that
and i'll just sit there with my wife and
just touch my wife or bobby bender
i'll touch him and i'll go listen to
these [__] two in the back
that just it's like two peas in a pod
it's [__] tremendous
but that's the only thing she's got is a
grandmother here
so it's kind of nice to see when they
[__] uh get together
saturday we had the date night you know
we uh
oh we went out we [__] because she's
playing softball now
this is my new life now today starts
softball and she's on a [__]
traveling team guys
so i'm part of the [__] travel
[__] combination now which i'm
excited about listen
i moved here for that for her to
experience a different life
and different things and it's working
it's working my knee is uh
three-quarter there you know i'm saying
i think they'll release me
from pt in about two weeks from physical
therapy
so thank you for all the well wishes and
the [__]
get well joey trust me i had a couple of
rough [__] nights there
but i'm happy i did it now now in
hindsight
i'm happy i did it it's like if you ever
think of doing it
always remember that you know just keep
putting the work in
and every four or five days i see a
little something i see a little bit more
improvement
more april 8th will be three months so
i'm at the two and a half month mark so
uh
you know i'm good man but i wouldn't
have done it without you guys cbd lion
you know mike helped me
my wife thank you guys for all the
[__] support and whatnot
and there was something else i wanted to
tell you before we cracked into what
we're doing
but not really i'll tell you what we got
today
i'm doing like i told you guys
wednesdays is me and you guys having a
chit chat
mondays is a zoom meeting just to
venture out and let this podcast grow a
little bit and let it
become what it's going to become but
right now i want to bring you
one of my [__] best buddies i missed
him so much
i had to call him up one of the funniest
podcasts
i ever did was with him uh we have great
chemistry together so
he's the guest on the show this week i
hope you enjoy this
who's the [__] guest mr greg
fitzsimmons [__] with your [__]
enjoy greg i'll see you afterwards
what's up kid
well just chilling in my office
you know my little home away from home i
got this
have you ever been in this office
probably not never never
five minutes from my house i got a
[__] lazy boy
flat screen tv coffee maker it's all i
need
that's what i'm gonna get soon pretty
soon i'm gonna get one of those up north
in north bergen and see caucus yeah nice
little office
again put some pictures up you know the
whole [__]
deal yeah right it's a place to uh
it's a place to masturbate but you also
do podcasts there there's lot lots of
options
i did a lot of things in that office i
never masturbated in that [__] office
shut up
are you scared of god no that's
disgusting i always feel like there's
cameras on me you know i'm saying like
in a hotel room you don't want to jerk
off
i don't trust nobody vegas you don't do
nothing yeah you got to [__] cover
the shower in vegas because you know
they're watching you in vegas
oh [__] yeah i bought coke and closets
in vegas did you know that i used to
smoke coke in the closet because
they're watching you you have to assume
they're watching you in las vegas
dude when i was in vegas one time i was
hosting the porn awards
it was the 25th anniversary of the porn
awards
and we're at the venetian hotel and the
tabletops it's on showtime there's seven
thousand coked up porn [__] out there
and they got instead of flowers at the
table center
they got a basket with uh fleshlights
and dildos
so me and my buddies are there of course
every [__] guy i've ever met is like
hey man i'm coming out i'm coming out
so i rented a house i rented a house
with five rooms in it and we [__]
packed people in
we all grab the fleshlights we go out to
the strip clubs i'm i'm the host so they
give me the [__] vip table we're
hanging out with
jenna jameson and tito ortiz and
everybody
so then i go back to my room and i got a
flashlight
and here's the thing about a fleshlight
you laugh about it
but then when you're alone in a hotel
room with it it starts looking at you
it's like you're gonna [__] me and
you're like i'm not gonna [__] you
20 minutes later i got my dick in the
fleshlight i'm jerking off into it i
finish
and now it's the next morning and i'm
and i'm packing a leave and i'm like all
right what do
what am i gonna do here i got i got a
dirty flesh like do
i do i put it in my bag and take it home
[__] no it's got jizz in it do i throw
it in the trash can
i don't want to horrify some maid so
what do i do
i slide it into the pocket of the
bathrobe in the closet
perfect perfect
perfect some poor bastard to go in there
with his jizz hand and get all [__] up
let me tell you something when those
flashlights came out like 2010 when
rogan was really pushing him yeah a
friend of mine actually got one
i went to his house he's like look look
what i got i got that i'm like
he goes you don't have one listen i've
done some disgusting [__] things
i have jerked off on the street in a car
i laid down and like whack off on coke
that type of [__]
but i gotta be honest with you i think
if i [__] there's
things that you do and you feel terrible
about afterwards
oh yeah yeah i don't want to say nobody
i
i couldn't look somebody in the eye if i
[__] the flashlight
and then then had to look at my jizzy
cocaine [__]
in the [__] thing it water hits it's
gonna be like [__] chicken soup but
you can i see it all slick on the type
like galveston like
[__] just some things that you do
it's like the first time
i you know i [__] hate hand jobs
really i was in michigan 1995
my shoulders bothered me i'm naive
and the michigan is the state the state
of the hand job it's shaped like a
[__] hand
i was naive to [__] in these
pulled places you know and i saw a
massage and i actually pulled over and
i went in and the chinese girl that
greeted me or the asian woman that
greeted me was
[__] hotter than [__] i had no
you know misconception i didn't have i i
was paid 450 for the week then
yeah right it was the feature act 450
and
200 was already gone and it's gonna cost
me a hundred and gas to get home there
was no
yeah i didn't go in there to [__] nobody
yeah i just went in together like a 30
40 hour massage yeah lydia tells me to
strip down right away i know there's a
problem listen
you're not rubbing my hips right you're
just rubbing my shoulders what what's
the strip strip down she came and then
they played the switch and bait
you know when i got there it was
whatever her name was it was
ali wong when i got there you know it
was a girl like as beautiful as ali wong
is what i'm trying to say she was
beautiful like ali wong
right but then they sent like a
grandmother and dressed in like [__]
drag
she had to be 80 years old yeah and she
rubbed my shoulder but
like two minutes in not even two minutes
and she's like
40 and i was so [__] embarrassed and
so humiliated
i didn't get the hand job yeah didn't
get the hand job but i always thought
about
how you would feel yeah just a hand job
and
yeah but the old lady hands here's the
thing about the old lady hands you ever
touch the skin
on the hands of an old person it's not
really [__] it it's like a baby lamb
it's soft yeah like my fingers
but i still don't want my hands on my
dick it's disgusting like it's just
disgusting there's just some things that
yeah you do and you feel so [__]
disgusting
afterwards especially when it comes to
sex like getting a blow job from an
awkward chick on the road on one of
those triple runs yeah like the potato
run one or two
you know yeah and the chicken you don't
even get the belt off she just jams it
down your [__] pants
just things that are just so disgusting
i remember one night just talking with
lee
we were coming back from a gig and i was
telling them about beginning comedy
those first couple road gigs what you
bump into and what you learned and
and it's just disgusting it's just
[__] yeah that's one thing i missed
out on because i've been i've been
married for so many years
and i never [__] around on the road as
i i never dealt with
any of that [__] shame for me it was
always just like
i go out on the road to work i don't i
don't come back with
the bobby lee stories and the joey diaz
stories
listen from you gotta remember from you
know
291 to 2000
there were the craziness drugs yeah sex
stories fingering a girl on the dance
floor in idaho falls and she had a yeast
infection
my hands smell like yogurt i mean i got
a thousand of those
i got a thousand of those old greek
yogurt
then after 2000 when i hooked up with
terry i was like you know what i can't
disrespect her on the road
but yeah i could still do drugs and all
that [__] yeah
and the drugs i did things on drugs that
were so [__] embarrassing like you
know
jerking off waiting for the dealer you
know you jerk off in between i remember
one weekend freezing
uh kelly lebrock's movie the woman in
red
there's a scene when gene wilder beeps
the horn and she gets out of bed
and they show her bush and i remember
freezing it just at that rate
like that just and just sitting there
and trying to jerk off your coked up
dick and your dick is an inch big
and you're trying to jerk it off and
you're [__] tiring telling that
you're doing this to it you're doing the
cappuccino it's just yeah
you know i think of all those things now
and i'm like i'm gonna push that out of
my mind because
nobody needs to know about that disgust
those type of things i did yeah
yeah type of stuff was just enough for
me to and the flashlight
there was no way i was gonna [__] the
flashlight you know why
because i know yeah i'm gonna know you
know
i'm gonna know that's all that needs it
doesn't matter nobody needs to know but
i'm gonna [__] know that i [__] the
flashlight
right and then i'm gonna go to church
one day because i usually don't go to
church but when i do i look at the 12
stations of the cross
and i think about all the creepy [__] i
did irish you know what i'm saying as
catholics we get beat up by our own
[__] guilt
oh yeah and that's when you think about
when you see jesus getting beat up next
you know i see myself jerking off with a
flashlight
and i feel depressed i don't eat the
cookie now i feel like a real [__]
sinner
so the psychological effects of
catholicism
[__] stop me from being a [__]
animal you can't eat the cookie man it's
all about the cookie
you gotta you gotta stay clean you gotta
pray you gotta show up on time otherwise
you don't get that cookie
it was so weird how when i was doing all
my craziness
like i was a sinner i'm still a sinner
but
i forgave some sin and some sins were
okay like i was such a hypocrite about
sins you know
i was okay about doing drugs i was okay
about [__] stealing
you know like it was okay there were so
many things but like
you know cheating on your girlfriend all
right
right like i had so many different i was
so contradicted by the [__] drugs
you know but one thing i don't know i
mean what is a you know a moral person
a truly moral person comes up with the
things they believe in
and that they'll live by and that's
their credo and they stick to those
if you're somebody that just goes oh
you're showing me the ten rules and i'm
gonna follow them
what does that show me that shows me
that you're obedient it shows me that
you're docile that doesn't show me
that you're actively figuring out what
your relationship to the universe is and
what you think is right and wrong
you come up with your own ten
commandments it's
uh no it wasn't right you know when i
was doing drugs like i think of little
things
like i think about robbing a cookie
place you know one of those little huts
that you see
yeah like i was that sick yeah i thought
i was walking the streets one night
and i saw the cookie shop and the
windows were open
i'm like i got to go in there and going
in there and getting 38 dollars
and walking home and like going what is
wrong with you wait you walked into the
shop
and stole it while they were open no no
no no it was closed i was going for a
walk i was walking home
yeah and i saw this cookie place i'm not
gonna say where because it's
embarrassing
uh-huh it's a little town and it's got
like a little mall you know on the
street and this was part of the mall of
stanford so it's like a kiosk
yeah kiosk right and i saw that whoever
ran the cookie shop
left the windows open like with a screen
like just the screen
yeah and i just popped the window and
went in there and i remember like
stealing the register that was like 38
yeah it was like 38 [__] dollars and
i stole a couple cookies and i'm going
to walk home i'm like
and here's the crazy thing i had 10
grand in the bank you know what i'm
saying like why would i ride 38
like [__] like that that's still till
today like i go jesus christ what type
of low life was i i didn't know
because cocaine would tell you there's
cocaine in that house like i would drive
by a house and go
i don't know i think they got like 20
keys in there and then i would bust them
it was like an old person's home they
had the garage filled with newspapers
there were hoarders or something like
that i'm like there's no coke in here
yeah and i would take something just to
make it be worthwhile
yeah and you on the drive home you're
like this is so embarrassing it's like
stealing a car
like i never robbed the car in my life
because you're in the [__] thing
once they pull you over there's no
getting out of it yeah oh i got into the
wrong car no
there's no getting out of it i never
stole a car stereo
like i never broke away my neighbor i
live when i grew up i lived on top of
the hill
and uh i had a neighbor terence mahoney
he lived in my backyard his parents were
eucharistic ministers
super catholic and they were you know
they had like 11 kids
and one of the kids terrance had a
little bicycle and i'd be late
i'd be late going to school in the
morning and i'd grab i'd go in the
garage i'd grab terence's bicycle
and i'd go flying down the hill and i
get to the bottom of the hill i throw it
in the bushes
and then they had a police blotter in
the local paper
and it used to say terence mahoney 34
suncliff drive
had his bicycle stolen again
yesterday and they'd take it up the hill
they give it back to terence i get up in
the morning i go in the garage i take it
i go down the hill again
low level cry that's not like stealing
20 kilos of coke from a guy's house
that was my petty crime i never fought
like the and i were watching the show on
crack
my wife she there was a show on netflix
about drugs in the 80s
oh yeah i saw that right and she put it
on and i'm sitting here watching it
and i looked at it and i go i got to
tell you something
this is all i'll tell you i'm very happy
that my friend is dead
and that my secrets went with him to the
grave from this time
like from 80 to 85 and
even 93 i did a couple things with them
that were [__] creepy
like drug things you know no no nothing
like we weren't into that
craziness these are just ripping off
drug dealers that would just
it was just creepiness but it was part
of the game
in 93 when i did it like i got you know
before 87 88 i was a [__] savage i
got locked up
and when i came out i said i'm going to
stay under a certain radar i'm still
going to be a savage
i know how to sling coke correctly you
know i know i'm not going to sell to a
cop
there were things i was going to do and
there were things i wasn't going to do i
was never going to kidnap somebody again
that was a big [__] mistake
live and learn right but yeah but i was
still going to do drug rips
if the opportunity presented itself if i
see some guy that's getting into the
business and he's not prepared
boom you hit these weak you know that's
what they were talking about they were
talking about weaknesses that got to the
point in new york where
drug dealers wouldn't even smile you
couldn't even laugh at a joke because
other drug dealers saw you that as a
weakness and that's what i did i looked
for weaknesses
you know these new guys would get into
it they buy an ounce didn't make two
thousand dollars and then like
give me a pound and you sell them a
pound and you just rob them back the
[__] pound i mean it was
yeah creepy [__] but there was some
really really creepy outlandish [__]
that he took to the grave with him yeah
i bumped into him in 99 and we had a
talk at a coffee shop
he was one of my brothers growing up
but he was very violent he was
he didn't give a [__] and uh
you know there was things that happened
that i'm not proud of but
i'm happy he took those secrets to the
grave with him nobody ever
find out yeah uh let me tell you my
friends
my experience my one experience selling
drugs when i was in high school
i used to sell mescaline me too purple
masculine for this kid named uh
andre i'm not gonna say his last name
although i'm pretty sure he's in jail
for life
and this kid was he was the blackest
human being i've ever seen in my life i
mean it was like an american
he was african-american he was and he
was tough and he had cousins in town
and like you didn't [__] with them you
didn't [__] with these cousins they were
they
they kind of like you know we had
projects downtown and they kind of like
ran them and so i started selling
mescaline for him because then i would
i'd sell it
to all the white kids they're all going
to grateful dead concerts and going to
the park and you know on a saturday
so i come home one day and it's a
saturday afternoon i walk in the house
and i look in my living room and my mom
is sitting at the dining room table
having tea with andre green i just said
his last name
so i walk in and i'm like what i'm
[__] like my
eyes are wha i'm like what is going on
here
and there's that killer sitting at the
table with my mom drinking tea
and so she went inside he goes uh hey
man you got my money i go
dude i told you i pay you on tuesday
what are you doing at my house today
well i need the money kind of early i go
i go here's the money we're done my days
of slinging
masculine are over that was it that was
it
i just i don't need on i don't need
andre green coming andre coming to your
house
i stopped selling masculine because i
graduated to cocaine
yeah like quail foods and cocaine a lot
of money in mexican 80 cents a piece
my mother's house is 280 profit 220.
what happened to that what happened to
that nice boy andre where's andre
he's doing 20 to life ma i'm not i'm not
sure i haven't checked in with him
i was like andre growing up like when i
went to kids houses
yeah they were like there he is the
[__] kiss of debt
i wonder what he's gonna get my son
involved into
you know there's a kid i hang out with
now still yeah
that he got arrested years ago he got
arrested about 15 years ago it was an
ugly type of arrest
and his mother blames me till this day
which is
true i'm the one that did coke with him
the first time we did coke together he
was a genius but
he continued to go and he [__] himself
up i'm still tight with him i talked to
him yesterday i talked to him tuesday
you know
but it i feel guilty about him because
he was
destined to be a [__] star like an
engineer he went to mit
no [__] yeah and he just fell off to the
wayside and uh
you know i helped him so it sounds like
he so he was doing coke at a young age
but he kept it together enough to get
into mit and graduate
he was one of those people that
i was jealous of growing up because we
took the same classes and i had to work
really hard to get a [__] b
and he would just show up and get an a
if you put effort in he got an a plus
which is how he got into mit
and uh i asked him once how are you so
smart
give me the secret and he goes listen
take notes and review all your
information every night
he goes that's what i do i review it i
review it i review it so when the finals
come
i know it in and out he goes so just to
work on it for an hour every night and
it was so weird
that i started duke doing what he was
doing and my grades went up
mm-hmm i ended up quitting high school
because i was a [__] loser not
because i was stupid i
i love that i love that you're sharing
this like
groundbreaking underground secret of how
to do well in school
you listen and you study so
he was like broken down for me i had no
idea like i was doing all this reading
and all this extra [__] to try to be
smart and he just cut it down for me
he's like
keep your eyes on her yeah listen to
what she's saying
and just take certain notes yeah because
the thing is
teachers write the tests so they're
writing down what they told you exactly
if you read the book you're reading a
bunch of extraneous information that
that teacher's not
that teacher is not going to include so
he taught me how to narrow it down
so i went from sitting to doing homework
and study hall
for 45 minutes to 15 minutes yeah
and i was getting like bees you know i
wasn't a genius like him
yeah you know i mean he was taking like
trig his sophomore year that type of
[__] you know right
and he got into mit we tried coke maybe
three weeks before my mother died in 79
like october
i was 79 and somebody had given it to me
and i was holding on to it for months
i'm like i'm not i'm never gonna do this
i would sell it from time to time like
somebody would give it to me and i would
sell it
i would get my hands on it and sell it
but i would never do it i swore i would
never do it in one day i had to go let
me bring it with me just in case
somebody wants to do it
we robbed a beer truck we ended up at
his house
and i told him like you want to go
upstairs there was like 10 of us
you want to go upstairs into a line of
coke that's the first time ever so we
were scared at first we were little
[__]
yeah we made vodka with uh
not gin peppermint schnapps oh and we
grinded down the ice cubes
you called them snowballs so we
sprinkled cocaine on top
nice we drank them first i'm like you
feel anything no do you feel anything
now
you sure no yeah and we finally like
took a little bit and put it on our gums
and
yeah i could feel the numbness and
they're like let's go for it let's just
snort
and we started like three lines and then
went back downstairs
and everybody was asking us why are you
guys acting weird i'm like nothing
we're not doing nothing another time he
had a wrestling
he had a wrestling finals he was like in
the state semifinals
of course a genius and a and uh he was a
[__] wrestler
and sure enough i give him a line of thc
aka angel dust
he's wrestling with the guy and he ended
up biting him and that night he calls me
he's like
you [__] i [__] bit the guy
in my head it was a street fight so i
bit him and i got disqualified because
of you
you know how you passed you know how you
pass [__]
your papers up like when the teacher
goes past your test
he sat in the end row of my row i was in
the front so when i would get his
answers i'd erase his answers and [__]
and he'd come back to me how did i get
up 72 i don't understand
i wrote that answer down somebody erased
it
you were the reverse curve oh my god i
used to [__] with him constantly yeah
that's great he asked to move to a
different role i mean
it was just uh and we're still tight now
he you know i
talked to him every other day basically
and one day last week
when when we when i switched over i
called him up and i do patreon
and i was going to ask him to help me
with the patreon i go do you want to
help me with the paper but i know that
he's
he's who bots you know what i'm saying
like he's selling coke but this one
he's making drug deals he showed up here
a week ago with a case full of sneakers
i mean it's [__] hilarious
he just called me out of the balloon
he's like i got a present for you
because he sounds like lee that's why i
love lei for all those years because he
reminds me of this guy
right and uh i think it was either
sunday a saturday he called me and he's
like i'm in the area
do you mind if i stop by i got a present
for you and i'm like i'll meet you
outside you can't come in
my wife the coven he pulled up with a
mask on you know the last guy i expected
with a mask on
he just got his teeth in he got new
teeth uh-huh
i helped him out with the teeth yeah and
he brought me some like
he brought me a pineapple
like this is no [__] he brought me a
pineapple
like he brings me like the most craziest
[__] you know yeah
a case of sneakers a pineapple sneakers
that didn't fit for my daughter that
they fit my daughter she's like who gave
him to my like your uncle jimmy
and then she goes where is he i want to
meet him i go you know you know jimmy
don't play that [__] you know what i'm
saying
jimmy don't want to come in jimmy's like
just take him
he showed up like with the weirdest
stuff and then he showed me he goes
look what i got and he showed me like a
vial of coke he goes i'm making a
delivery i just came by to tell you i
love you and
give you some fruit apples he brought
some tangerines
you know and stolen sneakers i mean
tremendous where else do you have
friends like that this is why i moved
back here
that's why i got to get back to jersey
right i called him he called me the
identity goes i need a favor can you
throw me some dough i'm gonna get
i sent it to him and he sent me the doe
back yesterday and i called him back
last night and i go let me tell you
something it has been an honor to have
you in my life
i just want you to know that you were
one of the reasons
i moved back here because you put so
much pleasure
he's always come through he's always one
of those kids that
when i was a kid and i was in the mess
if i was in a hotel room away from the
night before
and then the hindu was calling me we
need the 44 hours
for the next night and i wouldn't have
it i'd have to call him
yeah and he wouldn't just bring me 44
dollars he'd bring me two chicken
cutlets
a valium two joints a little bit of coke
a pineapple you know what i'm saying
like it was always a bag
my mom made roast beef like he took care
of me so much that today i can't turn my
back on him no matter what like
uh-huh there's times you'll call me he's
in a pinch i'll give it to you next week
i don't hear from him do i get mad no
because
yeah he basically saved my life when i
was a kid never told anybody what he did
for me you know how
people give you money like i had to give
coco 200.
he never repeated what he did for me as
a child
yeah he was just my friend right uh
he had a volkswagen that wouldn't go in
reverse so he used to have to open up
his door and
push his foot backwards he shot me in
the deck with a bb gun one day i was
coming out of my backyard he beat the
horn
and when i come around the backyard i
see him with a rifle pointed at me like
lee harvey oswald
i'm like what's going on austin i felt
like he
shot me with a pellet gun right on my
dick i didn't even get mad at him like
you know how you would say to somebody
what the [__] is wrong with you
i laughed my ass off because only he
would think or shoot me in the dick
because he told me
if you show me you'd think i'm gonna
shoot it and i remember one day put it
on his car
he's like that's it i'm gonna shoot it
sure enough i come out of the side of
the house
and there he is staring at me with the
volkswagen with a bb rifle and he shot
me right in the [__] dick dug
i got in this car we went to the city
copped a bag of dope and we laughed the
whole way through like jingle bells
that's [__] great [__] craziness
dude somebody was stupid enough i'd i
never shot a gun so my friend's from
texas
gail and she goes and she buys me a bb
gun for my 50th birthday
a pump you know a pump gun and so i go
out in the backyard and i got my nephew
there and my nephew is like a uh
he was like a navy seal and so he's very
he's very into guns he's got a glock
he's got
all these [__] israeli 12-gauge
[__] handguns
and so we're in the backyard with the
with the gun and we're shooting each
other
we're seeing who can take more pumps
shoot each other in the ass
and then he starts going let's shoot
cans so he's throwing cans in the air
and we're trying to shoot the coke can
before it hits the ground
so anyway we do this all day and then
the next day i get a text from my
next-door neighbor
who's got two little kids and they they
text me a picture of their blown out
window
with bbs in it their kid's room
she goes do you have a bb gun it took me
about
12 minutes to muster that straight to
right yes
i do
[Laughter]
i hate to go over that could have shot
her [__] kid's eye out i'm
54 years old joey what am i doing just
having a good time
just trying to have a good time hey how
are you doing in the coven man i mean
how you hanging in you got uh you got
places you can go that you feel safe
absolutely you know i have kept it light
yeah really really really have kept it
light
you get your comedy night once once a
week get that so we got one cake
and by the way for people who wondered
what i put in my mouth it was lucy gum
before the rumors start uh right here
this
is what was making all that noise uh-huh
uh
i've been okay i got vinnie's on
wednesday nights
right i got two more weeks now i'm
taking the summer off greg
there you go um
i think we did a lot the last 10 years
yep
i think that i didn't realize what we
had done
the last 10 years it blew my [__] wig
off
when i watched the comedy store
documentary it really hit me
of who i was and who i've become and how
much i've changed during this
pandemic you know yeah we've become
family men
now more than ever i mean i know you've
always loved your boys and you
you've talked spoken to me about your
boys but this has made you tighter with
them
yeah by now if your wife hasn't killed
you
or you killed your wife that means
you've gotten tighter
tighter i feel absolutely closer to my
wife i feel closer to my wife now
yeah um this situation has
really i was [__] up when i got here
i was just [__] up mentally you know
physically the whole la move
it just [__] me up and doing the
patreon
and doing the podcast brought me back a
little bit little by little
the podcasts were brutal in the
beginning i went bill burt style
and i must have lost a big chunk of my
audience and that's fine
because this is a lesson for everybody
that you have to start over again
yeah gain the public's trust again and
then it didn't help that 2 000 people
started a new podcast everybody was out
of work
so now everybody started podcast right
so things changed the podcast format
has changed in the world but i'm still
very happy
yeah um i'm a little disenchanted with
stand up but that's okay
that's funny you know because i i've
been feeling you and i talked about this
we talked on the phone last week
and uh we were talking about that of
like not feel like the honeymoon
the honeymoon period is kind of over
it's over but then i went out last night
we did this show because you know i do
that st patrick's day show at the improv
that you've done for me a million times
i put it on every year and uh so so
none of the clubs are open in la so
there's a golf course up the street from
my house and they've got this outdoor
cafe and they got picnic tables
and i and i found a little [__] like
uh uh
what do you call those wood things that
are on the ground a pellet
i guess he said that's a stage go go run
to the music store and get a couple
lights
we got a microphone i got uh jackie
flint kevin flynn
we got um uh uh what same uh
uh anyway we got a bunch of comics
and we packed the place everybody
[__] showed up was outside everybody
wore their masks
my daughter came out she's 17. she'd
never seen me do stand-up before
so i went up there and i'm nervous you
know because first of all i haven't been
doing stand-ups so i'm nervous on top of
that and then on top of that
this is the first time my daughter who's
been sitting across from me from the
dinner table for 17 years
i crack her up every night i do bits
with her every night she sleeps with the
dog in her bed and every night i take
the dog
and i do something funny with the dog
when i bring it into her room it's the
last thing that happens at the end of
the day
i make her laugh sometimes i take the
dog i put tin foil on his head
and i say that he's he's he's getting
transmissions from space
sometimes i put him in a roller bag and
i zip it up and i pull it into the room
i put [__] masks on them every night
it's a different bit and she like
but she's never seen me do stand-up and
i'm thinking to myself
like this is gonna be a formative moment
for her
to see what dad does for a living this
is my identity
this is my love she's always known that
i did it but she's never seen it
so i went up there joey i ripped the
tits off that place
i gave it i do my my all these new bits
i've been writing during
quarantine and and doing [__] around
people in the crowd
[__] on people and i got off and she
gave me a big hug and she goes dad i'm
so proud of you
that was such a beautiful moment well i
can't show my daughter my stand-up yet
for reasons unknown well the first thing
i said on stage was my daughter's in the
audience tonight
which is going to make this tricky
because half my jokes are about [__]
her mother
[Laughter]
[Music]
i can't uh my daughter's eight she just
came to me that day she goes i heard you
say the effort
and i was like it took this long don't
say it anymore yeah no
i've said it before but i think she
finally learned what it was at school
sometimes right now
you know every everybody curses in new
jersey you know yeah
right she had no choice uh the other day
called her mother an unconscionable ball
buster
and her mother went upstairs and she
goes did you hear the conversation and
she goes yeah i heard that call you
unconscionable ball
she didn't hear buster she just heard
ball
because my wife i was sitting there and
i'm trying to watch something she's
telling me some story but something i go
to stop
stop yeah you have been an
unconscionable ball buster during this
[__] pandemic
busting my balls when i'm trying to
watch something now you want to tell me
this [__] story
it's like that girlfriend that tells you
she got uncle molested uh
during halftime you're trying to watch
the game and during halftime she tries
to deflate you like your team is losing
you're not covering the spread nos on
your uncle molested you really i need
this now in my [__] life
you couldn't tell me this on valentine's
night when we're eating [__]
spamoni or some [__]
you just you know
my wife will talk about something at the
wrong [__] time
i'm sitting here in pain i just gave up
the [__] pain meds
i got a split and [__] headache you
know i had surgery so
it's [__] a major surgery and i'm
sitting here fighting off pain at night
just sitting out here like i [__]
want the dell waiting for my leg because
you know when you have
replacement surgery you have nightmares
that you're going to walk
and you're going to see your leg behind
you like that's my biggest fear that my
leg is just going to fall off from the
[__] knee down
yeah i'm going to be standing in like a
putts and all of a sudden there's an
ankle and i'm going to [__] faint
so i'm going
no it's [__] it has been and the pain
pills were a different journey that's a
different psychological journey and
until you go you know what
it's either pain or this feeling this
creepy feeling
i'll deal with the [__] pain i got
cbd lion i got [__]
yeah you know the arthritis cream i've
got you know
the cbd under the tongue really works oh
yeah
i tell you it takes away the pain by
have you tried the roll-on or the gels
because i got some of that that's comax
cryo-freeze that shit's [__] good
i got listen i got cbd line roll on yeah
i do the whole process i
roll it on i let it sink into the knee i
let it
air dry and then i put the tens on and i
pretty much electrocute myself and then
i forget i got the tins on and i go for
soda and the soda hits me in the finger
and i get like [__] a little jolt
like a little electrocution myself
i feel like [__] that guy in this
cave from alcatraz
like every night when i have the tens on
i go tonight tonight i electrocute
myself
i've added so i had such a rough [__]
pandemic
people do not understand that from march
to [__] may or june i was pretty much
knocking myself out every night with
drugs
what kind of drugs you name it whatever
would put me the [__] down you know yeah
for 12 years i went to a doctor and
every nine months every
it's 90 days he refilled the
prescription for asthma prime
the baby xanax the white ones i had a 12
year supply
that i never touched never when the [__]
do i you know
i get a little bit of anxiety before i
go on stage so i started putting
footballs their footballs white
footballs
i would put them in my top pocket and
i'd forget to take it when i got to the
store i would only take them if i you
know
sometimes they would go to the store
walk up the stairs to the original room
yeah and since they blacked out the
window i would get anxiety
yeah because i couldn't see the outside
and then i never touched them really for
12 [__] 13 years i didn't touch him i
think i took five or six of them
when i had that feeling you know yeah
during the pandemic i was eating [__]
ten of those things at night
yeah plus a thousand milligrams of
edible
damn plus reefer all [__] day plus
would you have a drink
i drank the first time on rogan's
podcast i had a shot of whiskey because
i was
i was doing the between the pills and
the edibles
i think the alcohol would have killed me
yeah i was gonna say you can't
don't [__] with alcohol when you're
talking all that stuff and that's the
thing about me like
during this when i left the hospital
after the knee surgery
they gave me 13 [__] prescriptions
jeez
muscle relaxers you know so right away i
went on a [__] i got them in the
refrigerator the little [__] the little
yogurts you drink for your stomach to
coat your stomach and
right i tried everything you know there
were pills i don't need to take like
they tried to put me on like an anxiety
medication it's all off to one of those
that
uh-huh you just don't need one minute
you're taking them jumping up and down
the next minute you're hanging from a
tree like chris cornell i don't know
right i don't want to hang those no
disrespect to chris cornell his face no
i know
believe me i know a lot of people that
have died i don't want to take none of
that [__] yeah
you know and and one day i finally woke
up out of the [__]
uh pill craze the little white footballs
and i was like
these things aren't making me feel well
and the edibles weren't helping
so what i did was when i came here i
changed everything
like i changed everything i changed my
diet i
stopped butter meat on certain days
i focused on sleep a lot more sleep and
i focused on
switching my time change which was a
[__] nightmare
really i was yeah i was going to bed at
one in that way that means i was going
to bed at four here
yeah so for the first two weeks i was
sleeping four to eight
and walking around like a zombo and like
looking at p i was so
petrified from uh world news tonight
with that [__] david muir he was like
[__] my
my [__] exorcist like it just scared
the [__] out of me i would be home every
day at 3
30 pinned to the tv counting the debts
and i come here and nobody's got a mask
on and people having barbecues in their
backyard
first couple weeks it was [__] brutal
to sit around like i would be dying
inside
but i said [__] it i'm going to switch
so i stopped eating edibles
and i yeah yeah that's it i use them
just to go to sleep at night
how many milligrams you take to go to
sleep that you don't want to know
that's a personal secret a thousand
i i take them to syringe form they come
in a [__] syringe it's a thousand
milligrams
and i put it in the tea i drink a
special two milligram tea
called keto that has cbd and cbn
and i will throw a whole [__]
thousand milligrams
in the [__] t and then 200 milligram
capsules of abx
oh yeah and then i [__] now i read
so i turn the tv off i read until i feel
little [__] robots
and i go upstairs and i dream in purple
everything's in purple like my dreams
like volleyball milligrams
you're gonna laugh but i got these
little mints
at the at the store because i don't i'm
not a big pot guy but i got these two
and a half milligrams
tremendous i got two dude they just i
come home sometimes and i pop one if i'm
stressed out
all of a sudden i'm looking the wife in
the eye i'm i got time for everybody
i'm i'm doing paint by numbers reading a
book
it just takes the edge off it's
fantastic it's got a thousand i can't
imagine a thousand
i'm [__] changing this game i'm gonna
[__] go to go
i'm gonna go to congress and tell them
that it's so weird how these edibles and
this marijuana
you don't need pills and i proved it to
myself
with the surgery with the pain pills
like listen the first two weeks i needed
the oxycontin after that i didn't need
it no more the feeling was horrible and
i kept having to take him
and i finally he switched me off him i
was trying to wean off
myself and i'm so proud i threw the
magic number away i threw 13 of them
away
were you taking those hard shits you're
taking those coral people it's like a
piece of coral coming out of your ass it
was like a fusion
listen the surgery [__] was five days
before i took a [__] and when it hurt
wow it felt like i was getting gang
raped by 20 [__] puerto ricans in my
[__]
because it was like yeah the [__] was
skinny on the way out but then
it opened up like a ball of constrictors
and hard hard
it was hard as a rock yeah i can't
describe the pain of the first two shits
but they gave me a medication that was
like a bomb
like they told you to take it after
dinner at 7 30 and you would
actually feel it
yeah and they would just clean out your
intestines i had to take a [__] during a
podcast one day
i did a podcast with uh brian sickler
came out monday
watched the podcast on zoom i had to
take it into the bathroom and [__] cause
when you gotta go now you gotta go
there's no holding back
wait did you did you continue the
podcast why are you doing it
what am i gonna call a timeout that's
for [__] you gotta you gotta commit
you gotta commit i gotta watch that oh
my god it was a tremendous three logs
they were sitting
and one blocking the other one if it was
the indians it was like indians made it
it was perfect
when i had a flush twice and then i got
up to pee he gave me [__] because i
don't put my dick in the toilet could
never
since i'm like four i'm like what if
somebody sucks your dick when you're
[__] you're supposed to pee in the
toilet
i get up to pee i don't wait so where's
your where's your penis while you're
taking a dump
in my hand i hold my my nut sack i don't
want
let me tell you something the third
night of this flight like driving a
stick shift
and i got that ball sacked but it's
gigantic let me tell you something
about the third or fourth night of the
surgery i went to take a [__] like to
try i had a fart like a twisted fart
and i was stuck to one of your little
chubby ribs yeah and i went in the
bathroom to [__] and i had my pants down
and when i went to bend down i had to
hold on
my balls picked up the toilet seat and i
sat on my balls
and i couldn't get up you don't know
what pain and confusion is
it was either between my balls or my
knees i didn't know what hurt more
that 300 pounds on your [__] ball
sack and they didn't do nothing
not even bruised they're beautiful my
ball sacks are made of [__] steel
that's how i know i'm a [__]
i am balls all the way to the end i sat
on my nuts and i remember sitting there
feeling
like that my nuts were stretched out
yeah like the skin like i thought i was
gonna and i'm like ah
and i just [__] had to like wiggle my
way back
up and i had to stand there for like
four minutes
and say god i don't know what i did to
deserve this
but this is a [__] karma killer right
here this is
i'm good now for a couple months i sat
on my own nut sack
how i didn't go to the hospital or i
mean i don't i don't even dude if that
happened to me that would be the night i
took the thousand milligrams that would
be that night
i don't even know man oh my god it has
been it has been but on the other hand
uh i miss you guys
i missed the comedy store i miss you man
it's hard not having you around oh
man you always warm me up when i see you
please i missed who i was
you know because i've changed and i
could feel it like when i drive now i'm
like
i'm a [__] suburban dad yeah right i
drive around a dead deer every [__]
day
like i live in the sticks and i'm like
my life has changed so much
i don't even know who the [__] i am but
lately
it's been coming back to me you know and
that's why i'm enjoying the zooms with
all my old friends because
i didn't want to go to zoom i was bill
burning until
the pandemic was over and then i was
just going to have live guests
but bill burr has built bird for a
[__] reason he's a [__] animal
he's
he could pull off that hour podcast by
himself i was having a hard time i'm
getting it now i'm getting a lot better
at it but i'm not bill burt you know
what i'm saying
so yeah i want to mix it up a little bit
plus i wanted to see you guys
i wanted to see you i want to look into
your eyes
there's something i got to tell you the
first one of the first things i did when
i got here
was i bumped into the kid that
owned the house that puerto rican nelson
the pervert in our
neighborhood lived in yeah i told you
that story first yeah yeah yeah
right about the profile my neighborhood
yep and it's so funny that
jimmy florentine told me a [__]
hilarious story about growing up in
jersey that there was a wrestler
a guy that was a wrestling photographer
that would take pictures and sell them
to kids outside the garden
but he was really a pedophile he would
tell you that he had two ringside seats
and to come down but then when you got
done you had to sit on his lap and he
would nibble
he hear what you watched he only had one
seat
[Music]
and i'm sitting there going jimmy isn't
it funny like in new jersey
we all knew who the pedophile was and we
[__] with him like other kids like i
got molested by
you let him molest you we tormented
puerto rican nelson
we we tell him come play football with
us he come out with the robe with no
underwear on you know
he thought he was going to get some ass
but we'd always shut him down we knew he
was a [__] pedophile to this day
you know the ice cream we let him buy an
ice cream and then he go
we're all going back to my house to look
at the globe right yeah yeah yeah [__]
yeah cause he had you globe he wanted to
show us all the places he'd been to
go [__] yourself i don't see no [__]
club but are you an english teacher
the [__] outta here
[Laughter]
you know who the pedophiles is and you
[__] with them in jersey like you know
until one day you get pissed off and
you're like 13 just [__] them up
like nelson didn't last that long for us
to [__] them up that's great now you go
to the midwest
everybody just gets molested everybody
gets molasses and they leave it there
you know yeah i remember
dog i [__] vividly remember
wanting to be a cub scout like a little
[__] like i went and bought the patches
and i was trying to wipe eyes by myself
with sticks and i'm like [__] i got
to join the boy scouts
i still remember where i went it was a
church and the boy scouts would meet in
the back
once a week in the church and i remember
going there and i wasn't
i was never an altar boy but i worked
the bingo hall and i never got a funny
feeling from the priest i could always
admit that i never got molested by a
priest or nothing like that
but i remember going to that [__]
cub scout weeble meeting you have to be
a wee boy
and i didn't like the word off the bat
like we blow yeah
right like i don't know about that and
then i i thought the guy was creepy
uh-huh i thought the guy like i went
twice maybe and i was like you know what
something right here and then now oh
it's all over television you know
if you got molested by a boy scout call
this number oh more than the catholic
priests they're saying
yes more incidents with the cub scouts
and the boy scouts than the catholic
priests
and i know a lot of people who are good
people who are cup scouts just like
everything else there's good cops
there's bad cops there's good cubans
there's bad cubans
right there's good irish and there's bad
irish how was your saint patty's day
beside the comedy eat some corned beef
i hate to well i i told you about that
comedy show so i told the people at the
cafe i said you guys are making corned
beef and cabbage i want you to order
about 16 cases of guinness
and then i baked i baked a couple of
iris soda breads my it's my
grandmother's recipe
i bought a couple sticks of that irish
butter and i sliced it up for i cooked
it so it was still hot when i got there
and then uh i listened to [__] clancy
brothers all day fighting songs
guys singing about four green fields you
know they
they stole my four green fields but my
sons have
sons and you know i'm [__] jigging
around the house i had
i love it i miss i miss new york city
because we used to march
every year since i was five years old
i marched in the parade with my
grandfather he was with the ancient
order of hibernians from the bronx
he came to this country when he was
[__] 16 years old
he worked for the electric company and
uh he raised
he raised six kids in the bronx on no
[__] money
and uh and he used to walk proud he put
on his suit with the sash
chin up in the air and you know all
these kids from long island and jersey
are throwing up and taking a piss on a
mailbox
he didn't look at that he looked
straight ahead marching like he was in
the ira
when he was in ireland he ran messages
for the for the ira from town to town
when he was like 13 14 years old what an
interesting [__] race the irish what
an
interesting race and what i've gotten
from them is nothing but
balls yeah like i've gotten balls from
irish people that i met like i'm like
man yeah when i was a kid there was a
kid chucky mcbreen he's the head coach
of the ramapo men's basketball team
uh-huh we still talk i love that
[__] with all my heart because
he was tiny but the ball's on him till
the end
and he would argue with you to the end
even if you were bigger than him
and you know what he wouldn't fight you
that wasn't his style
but he was such a classy guy i i loved
him and now
you know he his season that didn't have
a budget
for the covet this year so he got
cancelled
but it's so weird all the irish kids i
grew up with
they were very similar to cuban kids
we're very hard-headed
uh-huh we go in head first without
thinking you know yeah
yeah we swing first yeah and it's also
like
the irish you know we never had you look
at some european countries the french or
the italians
we never had that clothing style we
dressed like [__] pigs big
big wool sweaters and you know [__]
kicker boots
and the food's terrible everything's
boiled and uh and all that but
but when it came to loyalty when it came
to storytelling
people that could hold your attention
they respected that you were paying
attention to them so they gave you a
good story
and a good laugh and uh yeah and the
loyalty and the the fighting
spirit the independence you know this i
i go over that we were supposed to go to
ireland last summer but we couldn't go
because of covid
but we were supposed to go to cuba
remember i was going to go to cuba in
the spring
and then we were going to ireland in the
summer both both trips got canceled but
as soon as the cove dies down we're
going to both places
both [__] highly catholic countries
that's right
well it's a catholic island you know
it's really a [__] island but highly
yeah
catholic would everybody uh i respect
you
in a lot of ways you're staying
you're gonna hunker down and [__]
stay in l.a
you know i i don't live in l.a i live in
venice beach and that's a big difference
venice beach is a neighborhood you know
i know
every one of my neighbors for two blocks
in every direction
people have open yards no fences dogs
kids everybody's walking back and forth
i'm a mile from the beach
i i do [__] yoga on the beach on
sunday mornings
we play volley sam volleyball on the
beach on the weekends we got poker
nights
you know it's a lot of good-looking
young people a lot of hot young girls
walking around the neighborhood
it's the greatest i love it so you're
good down there
where am i going to go where am i going
to go this better than that
to me it's about like it's about being
able to
socialize without getting into my car in
los angeles
i walk down the street we have dinner
with some friends at their house
you know it's easy are you getting
vaccinated when it's your turn
i got one i gotta get the second one
yeah and you're gonna do comedy inside
you feel great
the whole thing yeah i got some i got
well let me mention my dates i got a
couple coming up
i'm going to be in uh next weekend i
don't i don't know when this airs but
i'm going to be in
um uh where am i going hold on
i'm going to raleigh north carolina
you know good nights right i'll be there
uh march 25th through the 27th
and then i'll be at philly and helium
the 22nd through the 25th of
april and then i got kansas city coming
up after that
maybe san francisco i'm not sure if
they're going to open the club
so you're doing your thing you're just
hanging in there no homeless by you down
there
oh we got homeless we got a lot of
homelessness yeah it's a big issue man
it's like you know people are pitching
in though
you know we help out at this soup
kitchen the people concerned we go out
there
buy some groceries drop it off on
sundays and
you know you try to throw them some
money on the street talk to them like
they're human beings
don't walk past them that's what i did
when i was in north hollywood but
towards the end it got a little even
more i had like personal protection
i had like a big black homeless dude
that was [__] six foot four what do
you want to do
oh yeah [__] it yeah and i would see him
and throw him 20s
yeah i would see him and pull over and
have my daughter give him a tornado you
see my daughter get into a jam you jump
in there g
that's nice no worries i'm killing
[__] for you d
yeah you know he called me d all the
time he was great i had a couple guys
i had another guy that wouldn't let me
help him give him food but let me give
them clothes
and [__] like that yeah i would bring
them vitamins you know
yeah this is you helping your community
that's the best you could do
you you can't help everybody yeah
but you do now look here's the bottom
line we live in los angeles it's got the
best
weather of anywhere in the country
anywhere in the country it it doesn't
get too hot in the summer it doesn't get
too cold in the winter
so people everybody wants to say oh look
at the californians look at you now you
get all these homeless
yeah where do you think they came from
they came from your [__] state
you know when they couldn't afford to
live there anymore because they're on
the streets you think they're gonna stay
on the streets in ohio
or [__] deep in texas no they're
coming out to california
it's not our problem it's all of our
problems and so you know people have a
reaction to it and they say
well [__] this i'm leaving town i don't
want to be around these homeless people
well how about you stay home and you fix
your home
that's no offense to you i know you
didn't leave because of the homeless you
had others no no no
but i see a lot of people they leave la
and then they want to [__] on it on the
way out and it's like
hey you know i didn't [__] on the way
out i i felt bad to be honest with you i
felt yeah
very bad but i always knew like i didn't
buy
i never bought for a reason i looked at
woodland hills and it just didn't
rub me the right way when i went looking
i think we went right after we had the
baby
yeah and i was like let's just see where
we end up
you know i was thinking about moving to
tennessee i mean
i had always been thinking it was either
going to be tennessee close to my
wife's family jersey or back to colorado
i just i couldn't go back to boulder i
disrespected boulder enough
uh-huh i already did time there i didn't
want to go back to boulder i didn't
deserve it
you know i was gonna go to like
telluride or something
oh yeah that's nice there but i realized
one thing
that even with you rogan all my friends
you know comedy wise i was missing
something
there was something missing i was i feel
that i had been gone
long enough i wanted my daughter to
experience
white castle burgers you know i wanted
her monday night she had a bad night and
i took her to carvel
and on the way there i go what are you
gonna have and she goes i'm gonna have a
chocolate ice cream soda
yeah i go when was the last time you had
one of those shoes well i tasted your
vanilla one and it was that good
to sit across from my daughter eating a
carvel
chocolate ice cream like for her to and
as soon as she got it she didn't say two
words she started sipping it
she drank it all the way to the [__]
bottom i had tears in my eyes
yeah saturday night is date night here
we all sit home and watch the
honeymooners at 9 30. oh no [__]
right she bunker last week he said [__]
and my daughter's like what's that
and don't worry about it he said [__]
on tv
2021 they wpix said [__] it we don't
give a [__] we're not gonna edit them
oh yeah followed by him threatening his
wife with domestic violence for five
minutes
no and then we watch you know and then
you watch the honeymoon as he's gonna
knock her out to the moon
right right and you but when she said
when she said what's a [__] me and my
wife nearly [__] our [__] pants
what do you tell them you know like what
that was the tv in the [__] 70s and
well she kind of let daddy tell you
about a story that happened up at a
massage parlor in michigan
yeah no but i would never i don't use
racial
epithets in front of yeah one thing i
don't because you learn racism at home
she doesn't she has african-american
friends and chinese friends and
yeah best friend is a jewish little girl
and she loves saying her name you know
the whole thing
so that's all been great but i do miss
you guys
yeah i think when the comedy store opens
it's going to really affect me a little
bit
right there was parts of me i wanted not
to open up so i wouldn't feel so bad
you know what i'm saying yeah but i
think once it opens up
eventually we'll have a little reunion
out there [__]
busting well your spirit your spirit's
always going to be in that back hallway
joey
yeah yeah we're going to feel you there
no yes it is man and i uh
i think that will be the ticket i came
to terms and once it opens up we'll give
it some time and
we'll get all the band together rolling
yourself
burr who's ever allowed in there you
never know anymore you know
right right yeah there's a few no shows
yeah there's a few no shows and we'll do
the best we can
until that time you and i will keep
talking every other week
yep we'll continue to be irish catholic
cuban brothers
and hopefully you can make it the cube
and meet my aunt
and because my aunt was going to hook
you up you know i called
you pick me up at the airport yeah and
bring you over and cook for you and you
know yeah
uh i need that i need that experience in
my life that that meet my sister maybe
you know you would have i haven't seen
my sister in 50 years you would have got
to meet my sister
how bad would i she was planning on
giving you an envelope for me like uh
pictures and [__] like that uh-huh i
think you're probably gonna send me down
with an envelope too
yeah i probably no i was thinking about
sending you down with an envelope a
little cash to give them because
if you send money the [__] communists
take 30
40 it's like having 10 [__] agents
and you send 100 bucks you only get 20.
yeah what the [__] is that so every time
i send money i got some extra money
because the [__]
the cubans take it so uh-huh but i miss
your brother and i'm happy you took the
time on a monday morning to talk to me
of course patty's day congratulations on
your daughter watching you do comedy
yeah
i can't wait yeah so i could take my
daughter to see me and for her to go dad
what the [__] was that you know yeah i
won't have that high energy i'll be too
old
by that time but i'll give it [__]
hell you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah you'll give it the best set
you've ever given it fitz i love you at
all my heart thank you very much for
coming on the joint
and uh we'll talk like we usually do
brother i'll be all right buddy i love
you too
thank you very much for doing this you
got it stay back all right take care
we're back [__] i hope you
enjoyed it uh
greg fitzsimmons is one of my all-time
[__] favorites you know i had to tell
them about puerto rican nelson then i
looked them up when i got back here to
see if we could find them and then we
couldn't find them blah blah blah
so it all worked out man but now uh
what are we doing what we're doing on
mondays from now on is
i'm contacting all the comics that i
miss
and we're going to do a little podcastio
and in time
you'll see all your favorites some of
you might like some of you might not
but i'm just getting the zoom thing
going because listen guys
i don't know how far this is going to go
and i'm sick and tired
of sitting here and expecting you to pay
attention to me for a [__] hour i
don't want to do that either
i don't want to listen to me for a
[__] hour either so we had to
integrate some guests in here
just to [__] uh give you a different
taste and a different look see what i'm
saying
i hope you people are enjoying it you
know uh i love greg
uh you could tell in our little [__]
chit chat that we both needed to see
each other
this is what it's been guys if you're
feeling a little weird a little
out of sorts right now hey man it's all
right
we're all feeling weird other swords but
your friendships are still there
and they shouldn't feel weird in other
sorts reach out they might make your day
look at my day
it's get i'm getting better every time
you [__] guys see me
and it's because i'm taking the right
steps i eliminate those [__] edibles
from my daytime life
and now i'm a normal [__] dad i'm
just a normal person i'm out of that la
[__]
i'm happy to be out of that type you
know like a little toxic type
environment that everybody
is needy and everybody needs to have
instagram friends and all this [__]
i'm out of that now i'm just a regular
suburban [__] dad
i'm not looking for nothing i didn't get
the ray romano movie
did i [__] cry i was like no someone
who cares really you're upset no
it wasn't meant to be god didn't put it
in the [__] path what are they meant
to be you move on
and they're shooting in queens anyway so
you know what the [__] rate of
transmission is like four point [__]
nine over there you sneeze
if you sneeze you get [__] covered
over there if you push out you get
covered so
everything happens for a reason this
time you have to accept things guys
sometimes listen
it wasn't going to change my life but i
just wanted to work a little bit
i never met ray romano i'd like to be in
his
directorial debut but it didn't work out
that way and that's
this is what life is about it's
adjusting
you got to have to take a couple no's
before you get to a yes
and that's it every once in a while no
no no no nobody wants me okay
there's gonna be one person who's going
to want you and that's that's been the
truth of me all my life so uh
hang in there i know we're going through
two uh tough times
but we're almost out of the [__]
weeds there's still a little shoe that's
gonna drop
but that still means we can still make
progress and still push forward every
week and still get
[__] what we need i will get the
vaccine in time i promise you guys
right now i'm not doing nothing [__]
spectacular to do it i mean
i'm sorry about uncle vinnie's last week
that they had a cancelled
there's a rumor going around but i have
covered uh
i took three [__] tests i ain't got
no [__] covert so i don't know where
the [__] that got
that came around like 10 people call me
you got covet not really
the club i don't know i don't know what
happened so my business i don't know
nothing
and i advise you to do the [__] same
i love you [__] i'm happy
you're enjoying
the joint i'm happy you enjoyed this
episode uh
i'm having a great time mike's having a
great time
and we're just trying to put this
[__] together for you every
monday and wednesday that's all we're
doing
no explosives no lights no [__] just
straight up [__] coming at you
and every week we're gonna get better
and better and this is what life is
about
it's getting just a little better every
week i'm i don't need to be
number one no listen i'm getting a
little better every week i know you guys
are too
so thank you very much for supporting us
thank you for watching
and i'll see you [__] wednesday
morning tip
top [__] magoo now for a word
from our sponsors
i love you [__] stay black all
right [__] i want to thank you
guys for listening
i want to thank greg fitzsimmons for
being a gentleman there's always always
a piss of having them on always a piece
of seeing him
guys i'm getting a lot out of these uh
zooms this is really
helping me a lot it's a it's a different
podcast and it's a
you know what i sometimes you got to
surrender
and i'm making you guys even happy and
that's all that matters to me is that
you guys are happy
before we leave the joint is brought to
you by
blue chew listen that's it you're
allowed to go out
you're going to be able to mingle you're
going to get your vaccine you're going
to meet
a woman maybe you've been celibate for
the last year maybe you've
haven't been able to you know make love
or whatever reasons
covered if you after you get your little
[__] uh vaccine
you can make it happen again make sure
that when you go back out there on the
field
you got confidence where it counts
that's where i come in that's where blue
chew comes in
you combat all forms of vd bluetooth
brings you the first chewable dick pill
same active ingredients as viagra cialis
at a fraction of the cost
and this isn't the [__] you know some
[__] uh fungi toe from brazil
you snort it and makes your descartes no
no this is science
blue chew is an online prescription
service no visits to the doctor's office
no awkward conversations and no waiting
online at the pharmacy
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com write that down
capital b l u e 2 capital c
h e u dot com and talk to one of their
licensed medical providers
once they approve you you'll receive
your prescription within days
it shipped right to your door in a
discreet package
the mailman don't know dick that you got
dick pills you know what i'm saying
anyway blue chews tablets are made in
the usa
and they prepared and shipped directly
way cheaper than any pharmacy
or anything you're gonna get anywhere
else so do me a favor right now i got a
special
deal for you like uncle joey does every
[__] monday
try blue chew for free what are you
talking about joey free
free use promo code joey at checkout all
you're gonna do is pay five hours for
shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code joey to
receive your first
month for free and as always i want to
thank blue chew for sponsoring the joint
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
line i can't talk enough about these
guys
whether it's the back ball the tincture
the kinesiology tape
the gummy bears and when you get the
gummy bears make sure you
get the raspberry ones i love them
they're all good but i
have a little [__] spot in my heart
for the raspberry ones i don't know why
the cbd chocolate i'm listening cbd lion
has you covered
go to cbdline.com read i need for you to
read their website
and see what's on there it's gonna
change your goddamn life guys
this is a game changer i have done a
whole surgery
with it i am no problems no nothing
whether you use the tincture the tape
whatever
you would need cbd will fill that void
go to cbdlion.com right now press in
church or joey
and get 20 off delivered right to your
[__] house
who else does that nobody go with cbd
line trust me they're the ones
that have bailed me out of this [__]
whole surgery in my knee
cbd lion the way to go and
the joint is also brought to you by
listen i just call them [__]
money
because it's draftkings okay it's april
the tournament madness it's [__]
heating up
it's [__] insane all right you're
sitting there on the couch you don't
know what to do
i can't get my vaccine [__] the [__]
vaccine
there's a tournament going on and
[__] draftkings is making it happen
again
remember last week i came to you you bet
4 hours
you win 254 dollars [__] that listen to
what they're doing this week over at
draftkings
you bet a dollar on any tournament game
if your team wins
you win 100 it's that [__] simple
pick any college basketball team
that's still running for your shot at
winning 100
and it only takes one dollar let's i got
two games for you got to look at
this afternoon you got oklahoma getting
14 and a half
against gonzaga and you got colorado
getting two versus florida state
that's a [__] start right there take
a look at those you got a chance to turn
one dollar
into 100 one dollar into 100
that's 100 to one odds this is what i'm
talking about at draftking sportsbook
there's no better way to put your
college basketball knowledge
to test them to put your money where
your [__] mouth is
with draftking sportsbook the best oh
college basketball ain't for me joy i
can't keep well who the [__] gives this
[__]
do you like money they're also giving
you 100 to one odds on select fighters
at this weekend's ufc 25 260. you got
stipe
you got miocic whatever his [__] name
is you got um
you got tyron woodley fighting you got
sean o'malley it's a great card
draftkings is safe secure and reliable
you withdraw your money when you want
it's your [__] money what are you
[__] around for who's better than you
nobody and who's better than your uncle
joey nobody and who's better than
draftkings
nobody that's why download the chop
created draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code joey when you sign up
to turn a dollar into 100 if the college
basketball team
you're choosing pulls off the win that's
code joey to turn a dollar
into 100 for a limited time only at
draftking sportsbook listen
i'm telling you from my hard drive this
[__] is [__] fun
i took a beating on saturday nights i
[__] was making fun of the grand
canyon
and they [__] covered those
[__] so
be careful anyway download the top
graded draftking sports sportsbook out
right now
use promo code joy when you sign up to
turn a dollar
into 100 of you the college basketball
team or you're choosing
pulls off the win that's code joey to
turn a dollar
into a hundred dollars that's the 100 to
one odds guys
come on give yourself a break and this
for a limited time only
at draftking sports book app here's the
fine print
you got to be 21 older new jersey
indiana pa
only i think tennessee colorado new
customers only
restrictions apply see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now if you got a
gaming problem
i'd rather you call 1-800 gambler or if
you're in indiana 1-809 with it
but if you're straight it's time to get
down and sling dick
download the draftking sportsbook app
today right now
and put a [__] dollar on [__]
gonzaga i don't give a [__] what you do
at a hundred to one odds you can't
[__] lose it's a beautiful big day to
be alive
thank you very much for listening to the
[__] joint i love you [__]
with all my heart
i want to thank greg fitzsimmons i want
to thank you guys i want to thank
patreon i love all you [__]
stay black not only is the joint coming
out today
on youtube but we have a lot of scottish
a spanish podcast
that comes out on patreon three dollars
five to ten
knock yourselves the [__] out i love you
[__] stay black
have a great week uncle joey loves you
[Music]
bam
so
you